this is where we left off in the
previous video
we use the inverse operations method to
find the value of x in this equation
let's move on to the second method
which is the transpose method
the good news is that this method is as
simple as the first one
we consider the same equation
x plus 3 equals 10.
before we actually implement the
transpose method we need to understand a
few concepts
look at this equation
we need just x on the left hand side and
we need to get rid of this three
this three as we can see is added on the
left hand side
here's the first concept
whenever an existing term is added on
one side we can transpose the term to
the other side by subtracting it
in this equation
3 is added on the left hand side
so when we transpose it to the right
hand side we subtract 3.
we can write the equation as
x is equal to 10 minus 3.
so this plus 3 which was on the left
hand side became -3 when transposed to
the right-hand side
remember this plus 3 is an existing term
you're not adding or subtracting it
you're just transferring it to the other
side by changing its sign
these two are actually the same
equations written differently
the second concept says that if a term
is subtracted on one side we can
transpose it to the other side by adding
it
if the equation was x minus 5 equals 12
we would have transposed 5 to the right
hand side and added it to 12.
the equation would then be x equals 12
plus 5
so here 5 was an existing term that was
subtracted
we transposed it to the other side by
adding it
this concept is valid for addition and
subtraction of terms when a term is
transposed to the other side addition
becomes subtraction and subtraction
becomes addition
transpose basically means transferred
the concept is similar for
multiplication and division
a term that is multiplied on one side is
divided when transposed to the other
side
let the next equation be 2x equal to 14
that we need to solve
since our aim is to have just the
variable on the left hand side we should
eliminate 2
and since 2 is multiplied on the left
hand side we transpose it and divide the
right hand side by 2.
we get x equal to fourteen by two
similarly a term that is divided on one
side is multiplied when transposed to
the other side
consider this equation
x divided by two equals seven
we can see two is dividing the left-hand
side
so we can transpose it to the other side
by multiplying the right-hand side by
two
we get x equal to seven multiplied by
so remember these four rules
if added then it's subtracted when
transposed
if subtracted then added when transposed
if multiplied on one side then it's
divided when transposed
and if it's divided on one side then
it's multiplied when it's transposed
now let's see how the transpose method
helps us solve an equation
let us solve the same equation we solved
using the inverse operations method
2x plus 5 equals 13.
i reiterate our aim is to keep just the
variable on the left hand side
so we transpose 5 to the other side
since it is added on the left hand side
we transpose it to the right hand side
and subtract it from 13.
we get two x equals thirteen minus five
this gives us two x equals to eight
the next step should be to eliminate two
from the left hand side
since two is multiplied with x on the
left hand side
we transpose it to the right hand side
and divide eight by two
so we get x equal to eight by two
that gives us the value of x as four
we can see that we get the same answer
using both the methods
the transpose method is actually the
same as the inverse operations method
just that instead of subtracting 5 from
both sides we transpose 5 to the other
side
it's the same thing as 5 and minus 5
cancel out here and all we are doing is
subtracting 5 from the right hand side
so we are avoiding a couple of steps to
write the steps directly
in the inverse operations method we use
more terms to eliminate terms on the
left hand side
here we just transpose them to get the
same result
in our videos we will be using the
transpose method